hello this is uh
a film in two parts the first film
uh will be going for the
information that you may need about me
and my history I don't know me
and it's about the book who was a
certification that I've decided now to
to award to those around the world who
wish
for me to uh do so
I haven't
rehearsed this so I may have a few
pauses and please bear with me
I started in 1973 but in 1975
I found that you could buy cytosenses
five volumes and it also he made a set
of cine films
accompanied with some tapes that had the
voice and you had to align the voice and
a cassette with the cine films to get
them to
to match so I was studying from fourth
queue
and to Second down in the UK
under cytosences films and books
I then met him in 1983.
in New Zealand
and then I formed uh
organization in 1992
with his request for me to become the UK
Ambassador on behalf of him
so that's a brief history of that and
that means I've been I've been training
for under him
for 27 years but physically twice a year
every year I would go somewhere around
the world on a seminar
and train with him for 19 of those years
until he's passing
he classed me as an Obama student once
when I was in America when he asked for
everybody to go out who was his Obama
students and I stayed behind and he
quickly shouted and told me to get out
there
in the break
he got someone to translate to say that
um he classed me as an iwama student
because I followed him around the world
and he said not even the iwama students
do that they they train there and see
him there so that was a great honor for
me
to think that he thought that much of me
and I thought that much of him
he was like a fatherly figure but he was
also very frightening as a master
because you've always wanted to
um
look up to him get the techniques right
and if you didn't you got his wrath and
he would shout at you constantly until
you did
moving on
um
in I I have
um his weapon Scrolls he decided at one
point that he would do his own taijitsu
certification and he would make his
weapons roles
that this is just one of them this is
the fourth one and
I thought I've changed the first three
in different places around the world
and he would post them to me
but it when I was and he was giving me
my taijitsu
dang rides
and when I took my fourth down he asked
me do I want ikikaya or iwa Maria and I
said Sensei you're my master I'll have
it one with you
so
he said when it came to my fifth down
over the years
that the only way I could get my fifth
down is I would have to at this stage go
too warmer so I in 1994 August 1994 I
went to Obama after a few days
he said I'm going to test you for your
weapons uh Boogie wizard certification
this he done and um
he
awarded me the level four
he said that um
he personally would start all night to
write them out because within this
scroll there are secrets that are handed
down from
Master to students and these are called
the true Secrets there's so much detail
in these Scrolls that you wouldn't
believe it in a conversation it's piece
by piece and telling you many things
that you would never even consider while
doing the attaches let's say
while I was there for three weeks
on the last week he said that he'd been
looking at me because we would do four
hours training a day
and there would be two hours in the
morning and they would be weapons and
then in the afternoons taijitsu
he'd been looking at me and in the last
week
he awarded me my fifth and last
book He was a scroll
but
we were about to go off from iwama to
Italy and then to do a seminar and then
from Italy to the UK Birmingham to do a
seminar that I was running
with him
because he has to stay up all night to
write this personally he said he was
getting tired and he might get a student
to write it and him tell him what to
write
now you don't have to believe me in this
but you won't find my name on any list
saying that I've got the fifth and last
scroll it's like as far as that goes I'm
now a master where I can test people and
I can award people the certification
because this is the permission that the
last scroll gives you
now why am I not on the list
well first of all there's nine others on
the list and I was hoping over the years
they may have done it themselves because
it's a great honor to hold these just
think out of all the aikidoka in the
world there's only nine people listed as
holding the five Scrolls
I wish there was a tenth and that's my
name on it I'm not
now here's the reason why
he came up to me and tested me and said
you've got the book he was a scroll but
as we're about to go to Italy and then
uh England can I post it to you
at the same time I said Scentsy I don't
have any more money while I'm here to
pay you cannot pay you in England
he agreed
we came to England Italy then England
I paid him for the seminar and I paid
him the money for my fifth and final
scroll
I never received the scroll
now you may think this is a bit stupid
but I respected him so highly
and it is respect it's not fear but it's
like a fear that I couldn't demand or
say Sensei can you tell me where my
Scrolls got to
in my thickness is stupid you might even
think I'm lying or not I have two
witnesses
to the fact that I did have it
so I do know a fact that and I'm not
decrying or putting my Scentsy down
but I'm just I know that many many
people
who got first second and third Scrolls
that tested in different places around
the world never receive their Scrolls
either
so you cannot take my word for it
I was hoping that one of the other nine
would do this but they haven't
now why am I doing it
well I ran a dojo personal dojos from
1982 to 2014.
I I would teach five six days a week
all that period
I now only teach seminars and occasional
in Cambridge
but when I was in iwama mid-morning a
Japanese student come running over to me
when I was tidying in the dojo it's
called the chief science shockado it
means the small kitchen
connected to the Dow Jones's house
since he wants to have a word he's
coming over please stay here
since you came over and his little
braces and gardening clothes
and he looked at me and he said Tony
the North America is okay and they're
safe with mine in our senses
Aikido
but would you give me your word that you
will keep mine and no senses
Aikido safe in Europe
well there's a lot of good teachers in
Europe
but
I gave him my word
I didn't realize until he passed away
what a heavy burden that is upon me
so I've been sitting waiting all these
years before I actually acted
hoping that someone would do something
now why is the time right now to do
something about this
I'm getting older
and
what he said was there's a lot of people
who haven't trained under me for a long
time
and I see that they've been learning
from my books and their films and
they've got a lot of points missing
and he was very angry with this he said
they're destroying my you know senses
Bucky was the weapons
so please keep them safe Tony and do
what you can to develop and um
like the the weapons secure
so that's why I'm now decide to do this
there'll be people criticize me but
um it's not a sense his way we shouldn't
be criticizing each other but there will
be criticizing criticism but I hope
you've enjoyed
listening to this story the next film
will be on the terms and what I will be
looking for and how I will respond to
those anywhere in the world who wish to
take part in the Boogie water
certification you don't have to follow
an iwama school you don't have to you
just have to be an individual who likes
to do the warmer weapons and I will look
at you and if passed you will have a
certificate with my
Authority that I'm happy for you to
teach the weapons thank you for your
time